for the hereafter
taken from the traditions of
the best of servants of allah the
prophet muhammad and
this book of course authored by the
esteemed scholar of islam
the late sheikh shamsuddin
ibn qayyam al jazeera
we were discussing in our last
lecture the issue of
how the prophet salallahu
and he would transition into sujud
from the standing position
by incrementally placing his various
points of sujud or limbs onto the ground
the nearest to the ground
first so he would start with his two
knees
and then his hands and then his forehead
with his the bridge of his nose
and when he would raise out of sujud it
would be the
opposite right so he would begin with
lifting his head
followed by his two hands followed by
his two knees
also discussed various types of things
which are prohibited
in prayer types of movements or
positions that would
that would mimic various animals
in their natural movements and we
discussed those
as well as he had said
he prohibited a person go down
from the standing position a camel
would fall
into a sitting or lying position
or quick movements of the head
to other than the direction of the qibla
that of a fox
waft
and that a person extend his hands
his forearms lay them flat on the
ground that of a beast meaning
lions or felines or he says
and he prohibited sitting in the
position that
a dog a canine would sit which would be
flat on
on a person's buttocks with the two
legs bent and the knees coming up here
and the hands between the legs
as we described before
up and pecking and going into sujud like
that of a crow
what
and lifting the hands when a person is
making tesleem
that of the tales of
of horses
as they swat with their tails
and we described these things in detail
in our last and previous
lecture ibn
[Silence]
he would make sujud on his forehead
and the bridge of his nose without
his turban being between his
forehead and the ground right doing
so when he would pray he would lift his
turban to where his forehead was exposed
therefore when he would go into sujud
the skin of his forehead would be in
direct contact with
the ground or whatever was on the ground
and it has never been authentically
reported that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make sujud on his
amen on his turban
so always a bare forehead onto the
ground
now there are two different
issues here the first
is making sujud with something connected
to the head
and shielding it from the directly
touching the ground
the second placing something on the
ground to shield the head
the first is something which the
scholars of islam have mentioned is
something that is
discouraged it's discouraged that a
person
place any garment or anything that would
cover his
forehead or her forehead from touching
the ground directly
or whatever is on the ground this of
course is not
something that will invalidate a
person's prayer
rather it's mentioned that the
companions
would pray in the heat of the desert
and of course when a person prays
on sand in the desert that has been
exposed to the sun
it becomes extremely scalding hot and so
the companions of
when they would go into sujud they would
position their
their imam they would position their
turbans or their head
garments in such a way that they would
protect their
faces and their foreheads from the
scorching
earth this is
something that is permissible
but it is something that is discouraged
without
a need to do so meaning if i have no
need
to cover my forehead with some kind of
head garment or something attached to my
forehead when i make sujud
then it is something which is
discouraged i do however if there is
some
need right such as
the example that we have just mentioned
with the scorching sun
scorching sand if there is a need then
that that which is disliked
is not considered disliked for any
necessity for any need
that would make a person need to do
this thing
the second thing is that
some people understand this to be
something that is going to interfere
with the
interfere with the validity of a
person's
prayer that if a person
prays and his head garment
shields a portion of his forehead from
touching the ground
or whatever is on the ground directly
that this will somehow invalidate his
sujud that is not the case
rather it is something which is
discouraged and there are some hats
you know that are made where there's a
cut out right here
in the middle of the forehead so it's a
hat but then there's a cut out right
here so that when you make sujud
and this is this is not the sunnah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
to design hats that have a cut out for
sujud is not something that the prophet
or the companions of the allah ever did
rather a person would lift it or raise
it to expose his forehead
and if his forehead is not fully exposed
it will not invalidate his or her prayer
the next thing we have is praying
without the forehead touching directly
the ground
and that is with putting some kind of
mat or carpet
or some kind of thing that is on the
ground and not attached to the forehead
this is something which the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
would often do
he would pray on many different things
and this is what ibn al-qayyim now will
get into he says
and often times the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would make sujud directly onto the
ground
without there being any furnishing on
the ground
and he would even make sujud directly
onto the ground
even if it had rained and there was mud
or water on the ground he would still
make
direct sujood onto the ground
and sometimes he would pray on
a sheet that was made from
the date palm tree is something that
covers right and this is why
a head garment that covers the head is
called a
khimar in the arabic language and this
is where the word
hammer comes from which is alcohol or
intoxicants because it covers the mind
and a person can no longer think
properly so
he would make sujud on this as well
and he would also make sujud on a mat
which was woven
from a date palm tree while forward
and he had also been recorded to have
prayed and made sujud onto
a animal hide
that was tanned of course
when something is
slaughtered or when there is a dead
animal
the hide is also considered to be
impure until it is tanned
tanning is when a person it's a certain
thing it's it's
you know it's garnished in
a tanning solution whatever it is and
then it is put in the sun to dry
this is called tanning and this is
something which purifies any hide
right any hide
that is otherwise impure
is purified by by
tanning so when you go to the store you
buy some leather jackets
leather coats you buy a belt whatever it
is that's made out of leather
you don't have to look if this is
something that has been
slaughtered according to islamic law
because even if it was not
the fact that this belt or this jacket
or these gloves or
shoes or whatever it is the fact that
this has been tanned
makes it pure makes it pure
he says
says and when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make
sujud he would
clearly plainly
place his forehead and the bridge of his
nose
onto the ground flatly right
this is a mistake that is constantly
observed
and that is that many people make sujud
on the forehead
and the nose does not touch the ground
the nose must touch the ground in order
for a person's suju to be
valid a person sujud is not valid
if his nose does not or her nose does
not touch the ground
and when we say touch the ground we are
speaking about
and al-musa
not only that a person place his
forehead and the bridge of his nose
onto the ground clearly
but also that there be
some kind of pressure that is placed at
the hammer
that a person must place pressure onto
the forehead
and the nose because
in actuality the nose is part of the
face
and when we make sujud it is actually
the face that is making sujud it's not
the head
it's not the forehead alone it's the
face this is why the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would often make dua in his sujud
my face has prostrated to the one who
has created it
my face and so
the forehead and the nose must touch the
ground in order for
a person's suju to be valid
there is a narration in a sunnah in
which the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says
and it's the narration of abdullah ibn
abbas
will be allah
i have been commanded to prostrate
on seven parts
of my body seven parts seven points
of prostration on the human body and so
he said
the forehead and the nose
the two hands the two knees
and the edges of the two feet
meaning not the toes but that the toes
be bent
facing towards the qibla and that the
edges of his feet
be touching the ground this is a how a
person is to make sujud
when he would make sure he was
he would open up his arms they would not
be stuck to his sides
he would open them up in some narrations
he would open them up
wide enough that if a hadith
which is a small goat a little baby goat
if it wanted if it it could essentially
walk
underneath his arm while he is in sujoot
and so he would open his arms up and he
would keep them wide
and we mentioned that in sujood it's
the same way that when a person
raises his hands in prayer either
up to the shoulders up to the ears
shoulder width
right this is how he would be in sujud
sallallahu alaihi
and if something we wanted to walk
underneath his arm it could
hypothetically now some people
read this they learn it and they
exaggerate and again we have mentioned
something that is a concept of
a luffy sunnah which is
a concept of exaggeration
in following the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
what does that mean exaggeration
exaggeration meaning
taking it too literally to
too harshly to the point that a person
stretches it beyond what was intended so
when a person is making surgeries in
this position
sometimes you see people open up their
arms they have read these
narrations they open up their arms like
this
in a very awkward way and they're taking
up a huge
amount of space and then they're even
worse than that that people try to
exercise this
during congregational prayer and that's
just not something which
should be done a person in prayer has to
hey he has his own
space that he has to maintain and
everybody else gets their space as well
you do not
practice your prayer at the expense of
the discomfort of others this is not
something which
is permissible and so opening up the
arms very exaggerated this is
what's meant is that shoulder width
either the height
of his shoulders or his ears so imagine
if this was the ground
it would be this his
forehead and nose would be on the ground
and his arms would not be
in it would be out this right this
is how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
would make sujud
and he would spread his arms you know
open them up that the whiteness
of his armpit would would show
right so if a person is in the sun often
obviously the parts of his skin which
are exposed to the sun
most regularly these
are the parts that
are going to be darker so you know if a
person takes his t-shirt off it lives in
a
sunny area oftentimes it'll the
the part of his body where the garment
is always there will
will be wider than the rest of his body
and so this is why it is mentioned that
the whiteness of his armpits
would show so he would open his arm
significantly
in a way that his the whiteness of his
armpits would show based on whatever
kind of garment he happened to be
wearing at the time
and he would place his hands
at the at the
position where his shoulders and his
ears would be
so he would be this
he says and he would
be well balanced in his sujud
and he would point his toes towards the
qibla
he says
and he would also place his full hand
onto the ground
with his fingers extended
he says
and he would neither open his fingers up
in sud this
nor would he cup them together rather he
would just place them
naturally
now before we move on to this
there is another issue that we'd to
mention and that is
where the feet should be now
it's established in sahih al-bukhari
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he would stand
for prayer when he would be in when he
would be in sujud
that his toes and every part of his body
would be
pointing towards the equivalent right
they would be pointing towards the qibla
and so his fingers would be this
when he's in sujud and also that his
toes
would be pointing towards the qibla now
there is an opinion amongst some of the
scholars of islam that
he would
he would put his two feet together
he would put his two feet together like
this
and so it would appear as if there's
only six
parts so his two feet would be put
together just this
this is a weaker opinion
this is not an opinion of any of the
four imams
it's based on a narration in sahih
muslim
on the authority of aye
when she mentions that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam she had awoken
one night to find him not in bed
and she had felt around of course
there's no lights in
in the the homes
at that time there's no electricity
there's no lit fires
and she would she had felt around and
her hand had touched both of his feet
right his her hand touched both of his
feet
and in another wording of this narration
which is in
that his two feet were together this
additional wording his two feet were
together
this is an inauthentic wording this
narration is not authentic
the only authentic narration is that she
put her
hand on his feet and she felt his two
feet
so some scholars say well the only way
you can
feel is two feet with one hand as if
they're together
and that is something which is
subjective
and highly speculative rather
as mentioned in
that the when a person prays his feet
should be
apart about six or seven inches apart
right because if he puts his feet or her
feet
this and they are spread in that
way shoulder
shoulder width apart the toes will
naturally face towards the qibla
when a person is in sujud but if a
person puts them together what happens
well they start to point outwards and
they can no longer be facing towards the
qibla
[Arabic recitation]
is that
during sujud a person should
space his feet out not put them together
but space them out with the toes
pointing towards the qiblah
subhan allah
allah and he also commanded that subhana
rabbi
allah be said when a person is
instituted
and he would also say
in his sujud subhannak
meaning free from any imperfection
you are oh my lord allah
and i hereby proclaim
all praise that is due to you
o my lord o allah please forgive me
and he would also say in his sujud
similar to what he would say in his rook
islamic
to you alone i have
prostrated and in you i have believed
and to you
i have sub i have
and to you i have
a slimt meaning to you i have
offered myself as a muslim
which is adherence right i have adhered
to you
my face has prostrated to the one who
has created it
and given it its image and has
struck its hearing and
vision meaning given my face it's it's
hearing and vision
blessed is allah the best of
creators
and he would likewise often say
oh my oh allah forgive me
all of my sins
that which it that of my sin which is
very substantial and that which is very
minute and the first of my sin and the
last of my sins
and the public and private of my sins
[Silence]
which translates to oh allah forgive me
all of my sins forgive me my ignorance
forgive me for my wastefulness
in any of my affair and forgive me for
that which you are more knowledgeable
of than even myself oh allah
forgive me for that which is serious
and that which is not
serious that which is only jokingly and
that which is
earnestly and seriously
forgive me for all of my
mistakes and forgive me for all of the
things that i have done
on purpose intentionally intentionally
and
mistakingly and all of the previously
mentioned
traits are something that i have
all of those kinds of mistakes oh allah
forgive me what i have put forth
what i have left behind forgive me for
that which i have kept secret
and that which i have made public you
are my
lord the one that i worship
none is rightfully worshiped by you
in nahum
he says and he commanded
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
encouraged that we
work hard in our sujud that we make
sincere earnest
dua and that we make vehement dua
while we are in subdued supplication and
he said
that the position of sujud and
supplication therein
is a position which makes it extremely
likely that allah will will answer our
prayers
in such a position
he says now we move on to another
chapter we have finished
then after completing his sujud the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam would
raise his head
while making tear without raising his
hands so it's not rukur
it's not going into sujud
it's not before roku or after the
after sujud there's no raising of the
hands but the tekbir is made
simultaneously with the beginning and
ending
of the transition from one position to
the other just all of the
he would sit
and he would lay his
left foot down behind his buttocks and
he would rest his weight on it
right
and he would then set up his right
foot so when a person sits
on his you know he bends his knees he
sits down
onto his feet right
he would place his left foot underneath
his buttocks
and it would be he would rest on it
and the right foot he would set up with
the toes facing towards the qibla
right and i'm sure you all know roughly
what it is i am speaking of
this is how he would sit now is this the
only way a person can sit
no if this is somehow uncomfortable if
this is something that a person can't do
then they sit anyway that is considered
sitting as long as it is not
sitting in a way that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
has prohibited and we discussed that
previously
some people can only sit on a chair some
people can only sit
with their legs extended some people may
have to sit
cross-legged whatever it is as long it
is as it is not
as we have mentioned and he would place
his two hands on his
on his thighs so he's sitting and he
would place his hands
right on his thighs
now he would place his hands on his
thighs
and his elbows would also be touching
his
thighs right so he's got his his knees
out
and he's got his hands and his elbows
right touching his thighs
and the the fingers
right where the where the knuckles
meet
the hand that fingers join with the
hand
knuckles he would place his
hands in a way where part of his hand is
on his knee
and part is on his on his thigh
min
and he would with his right hand
he would make similar to a fist
but he would take his middle finger and
his thumb
and he would make a ring right he would
make a ring
with it so he's got two fingers
closed and he's got a ring made
right between his middle finger and his
thumb
and he's got this finger extending
straight out and he would place that
just this
exactly this now some people have
read this narration
and they misunderstood what is meant by
and they thought what's meant by meaning
to make a circle
was not with his middle and thumb rather
to make the circle with his
with his index finger while a person
is making it
so you see people making dua this
and
circling making a circle in the air like
this
this is wrong right what's meant is the
circle is to be made here
with the thumb and the middle finger
right with the ring finger and the pinky
clasped
this and the the index finger
pointing out towards the qibla
zuma
[Silence]
and he would extend his
finger out right and he would move it
very slightly
in a stiff manner and he would make dua
with it
meaning you know as as a as if you're
making dua here and you're kind of
moving your hands alohuma
right same kind of you're expressing
your dua with the finger this is not the
only
time when a person would make dua with
with one finger
right the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to make dua
just this with one finger during
he would never raise his hands on the
mimble rather he would only make dua
with his
finger this
right and this is the sunnah making dua
in the
right and it's also the sun now when a
person is into
it they are making dua with the sub
and he would say in this position o
allah forgive me and have mercy upon me
guide me and bless me
this is how ibn abbas
described the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to have made prayer
and
that when he was in this position right
between the two sujud
he would say my lord forgive me
then
right and
he would rise up
this is meaning between the two sujud he
would place his finger this and he
would move it now this is something
which the scholars of islam differ on
dead the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam put his finger
out between the two sujud or only in
tashahud
ibn khayim views and his view is very
strong he
is a scholar of hadith he is actually
in the science of hadith he views the
this narration to be authentic
that between the two sujud the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would raise his finger
and he would move it and say
or he would make the other dua
right between the two just tashahud
just this is one opinion
right and there is a narration and sunna
nabi dawud that
affirms this other scholars of hadith
say no this narration actually is
what is called the makhlub it's in the
science of hadith it's a very particular
type of mistake
that a narrator of hadith makes when he
switches something in the narration
because he misremembered
right and this
is do i excuse me a debate that has
taken place
in ancient times and contemporary
amongst the scholars of hadith on
whether or not the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
would raise his finger
it would appear that the correct opinion
is that he would not
raise his finger between the two sujud
and actually
this is something that the
narrator made a mistake in and it is
hadith that he would raise his finger
and make dua in tashahud not between the
two
sujud between the two the person's hands
are just normal and they say subhan
they would say between the two sujud
right or a person would say between
the two sujud
[Arabic recitation]
right the different narrations found in
sunan
either way he then mentions that you
know
we understand that he would go back into
sujood again exactly the same way that
he made sujud in the first
then he would rise up from sujud
he would rise up
he would rise up on the balls of his
feet
so when he rises up when he goes from
the first sujud into the sitting
position
he would rise up mufterish
in the way that we described but when he
would come up from the second
sujud going into a standing position
again
he would not he would go straight up
with his two feet
put up just they are in sujood rise
up onto his
knees and then rise up onto his feet
this is how abnor described
so he would have his hands on his thighs
as he would rise up
sallallahu
and when he would reach the standing
position
allah would begin to recite immediately
not delaying his recitation as he
would
in the very first record now this is
another issue
which the scholars of philip debate
and differ on and it's something which
has been
kind of misunderstood and it is called
gelset
what is
is that after the second shoot
before going into the standing position
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was narrated in sahih al-bukhari in
sunnin
hadith that
he would sit then
he would put his hands either his fists
or his
palms into the ground and stand up so he
would sit
just as he used to sit between the two
sujud
then he would stand up from there so he
wouldn't go straight from sujood to
standing
rather he would rise to the sitting
position
then he would rise up
this is called and its exact translation
is the sitting of
relief basically or rest
resting sit what is that that is that
instead of a person losing his balance
losing his composure going straight out
of
suju the person should just sit first
and then
from that position going to the standing
now
some of the scholars of islam view this
to be a sunnah
and others view this to be something
which is specific
in order to understand this we have to
understand something about the narrator
the companion who narrated this to us
his name is he's also the narrator who
narrates the statement of the prophet
he's the narrator of that hadith
pray as you all see me pray
now malik ibn huwaidith
only spent
about 20 some days in the company of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
he came to visit with a group of other
young men from his
hometown they went there to learn
salah from the prophet salallahu
they spent 20 some days there and then
they went home
and this was in the last year or two
either in the ninth or eighth year after
hijrah
so it was in the last year of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
life
that they spent then they went back to
their homes
and by the time they had gotten back
some time had elapsed
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam had passed away
so when they were there they
observed that when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would come up
from sujud the second sujud he would sit
then he would stand up but there is a
problem and that is that
none of the other companions of the
prophet salallahu
who prayed with him all of the time abu
bakr and
all of these companions that were
constantly around the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
in the first row narrating to us exactly
how he would pray
none of them narrated to us this jel
is tiraha right so
now we understand when we collect all of
that we say well why did abu bakr an al
maranath man
people who described the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's prayers
such
why isn't it mentioned they described to
us in great detail
down to what exactly the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would recite
and when
how he would recite how he would stand
how his fingers would be
but they failed to narrate jealousy
why is that why is it only malik
who only spent a very small amount of
time at the end of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's life
why is he the only one to narrate to us
jesus
from this when we look at this we come
to the conclusion that when malik
and his companions saw the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he was either ill or he was at near the
end of his life
and he was old and he needed to have
that gel
instead of standing straight up he was
not as youthful
as he was earlier right
so he would have this gelset illustraca
but not all of the time the companions
understood this jealousy to be something
that he would do if he needed to
if he's tired if he's he's got some
problems in his knees whatever it is if
a person
is
this is this is the conclusion that we
arrive at
and this is the conclusion that ibn
kayyem arrives at here
that there is no jail is unless a person
needs to make jail
either way if a person wants to make
jealousy
that's fine but it's taken out of
proportion and this is what the scholars
of islam refer to as
sunnah
aspects of the sunnah way too far
right and making them into something
that is a bigger
issue than it needs to be so for example
one of the things people misunderstand
with jealousy
is that they make it really long so
they'll sit
right and there's people praying behind
them everybody have
half the people stood up half the people
are still sitting there wondering what's
the imam doing here
right and then he'll stand up this is
wrong
none of the scholars of islam describe
jealousy
to be this is to be extremely brief
so brief in fact that the scholars of
phil describe it as being
as if he sat on some lit coals what does
that mean
is that he would sit up as if he was
sitting on hot coals
very very brief sitting just
and then he would move into his position
that's the first thing
so if you want to make jealousy you need
to make it that way
second of all if you are praying behind
any man
who does not make jail
because this will cause you to lag
behind unnecessarily
behind the iman right you do not make
jealousy
if the imam doesn't make jill a third
thing if you are an iman and people
don't know about jealousy
which most people don't you are not
going to make jail
because most people do not watch what
the imam is doing
this is these are some issues with
regards to jealousy
why do i bring it up well i bring it up
because it's become an issue of
contention amongst people like
the hadith that's a very broad term
he is
so this is a very dangerous statement
when you say this is the sunnah you're
implying that
anything else is not the sunnah and
if something is opposite of the sunnah
it is now iptida
fideen right it is innovation and what
this does
is it causes us to make
points of contention which are are not
so cut and dried is it absolutely clear
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
all of his life no it is not
right as a matter of fact overwhelming
amount of evidence that he did not
unless he was ill or very old
is it absolutely one hundred percent
clear that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would place his hands on his
chest and salah
no this is not absolutely clear
[Silence]
foreign
where that would be all of the
narrations that
mention where that is on the chest on
the navel below
above all of those are weak narrations
so when we use the word sunnah we have
to be very careful
right because it can become a divisive
contraption that
this is the sun and if you do something
else you're intending to diso
disobey the prophet sallallahu alaihi
and that is not the issue at all
this is enough for tonight to allah